the geometric sequence a sub I is
defined by the formula where the first
term a sub one is equal to negative
one-eighth and then every term after
that is defined as being so a sub I is
going to be two times the term before
that
so a sub I is two times a sub I minus
one what is a sub four the fourth term
in the sequence and pause the video and
see if you can work this out well
there's a couple of ways that you could
tackle this one is to just directly use
these formulas so we could say that a
sub four well that's going to be this
case right over here a sub four is going
to be equal to two times a sub three
well a sub three if we go and use this
formula it's going to be equal to two
times a sub two each term is equal to
two times the term before it and then we
can go back to this formula again and
say a sub two is going to be two times a
sub one two times a sub one and lucky
for us we know that a sub 1 is negative
one-eighth so it's going to be 2 times
negative one-eighth which is equal to
negative one-fourth negative 1/4 and so
this is negative 1/4 so 2 times negative
1/4 is equal to negative 2/4 or negative
1/2 and so a sub 4 is 2 times a sub 3 a
sub 3 is negative 1/2 so this is going
to be 2 times negative 1/2 which is
going to be equal to negative 1 so
that's one way to solve it another way
to think about it is look we have we
have our initial term and we also know
our common ratio we know each successive
term is 2 times the term before it so we
could we could explicitly this is a
recursive definition for our geometric
series but we could explicitly write it
as a sub I is going to be equal to our
initial term negative 1 8 and then we're
going to multiply it by 2 we're going to
multiply it by 2 I minus 1 times so we
could say times 2
to the I minus one power let's make sure
let's make sure if that let's make sure
that makes sense so a sub one based on
this formula a sub 1 would be negative
1/8 times 2 to the 1 minus 1/2 to the
0th power so that makes sense that would
be negative 1/8 based on this formula a
sub 2 would be negative 1/8 times 2 to
the 2 minus 1 so 2 to the first power so
we're gonna take our initial term and
multiply it by 2 once which is exactly
right a sub 2 is negative 1/4 and so if
we want to find the fourth term in the
sequence we could just say well using
this explicit formula we could say a sub
4 is equal to negative 1/8 times 2 to
the 4 minus 1/2 to the 4 minus 1 power
and so this is equal to negative 1/8
times 2 to the 3rd power and so this is
negative 1/8 times eight negative 1/8
one day give 1/8 times 8 which is equal
to negative 1 and you might be a little
bit a toss-up on which method you want
to use but for sure this second method
right over here where we come up with an
explicit formula once we know the
initial term and we know the common
ratio this would be way easier if you
were trying to find say the 40th term
because doing the 40th sirum recursively
like this would take a lot of time and
frankly a lot of paper